new in theaters this weekend Star Wars
the rise of Skywalker and cats well you
see this is your weekend ticket what are
you doing there or Threepio taking one
last look sir
at my friend's Star Wars the rise of
Skywalker is said to be the last in the
nine films Skywalker saga as we will see
ray and the remaining resistance face
off against kylo Ren and the first order
JJ Abrams once again returns to the helm
and their promises to be plenty of
surprises left including the possible
return of Emperor Palpatine this movies
for you if you're a fan of Star Wars
you're looking forward to seeing how the
saga wraps up or baby Yoda you're hoping
and there will be are you going to try
for a different life become
the Broadway musical Cats hits the big
screen and is retold through a mix of
live-action and CGI in the film we are
introduced to an alleyway of singing
dancing cats just trying to make it
living on the streets the cast includes
singing and dancing James Corden Judi
Dench Idris Elba Jennifer Hudson Jason
Derulo Ian McKellen Taylor Swift and
rebel Wilson this movies for you if you
like the Broadway musical Cats you're a
fan of musicals turned movie or if you
realize saying Jason Derulo three times
makes him appear watch this Jason Derulo
oh hey what's up man just chilling Jason
Derulo you should say that is your
weekend ticket well you see and come
back next week to see spider-man team-up
with pigeon man you'll see